well what is it like to create the music
and the songwriting where does it come
from most of the time it's a job oh I
love it but most of the time you know I
have to know why I'm writing whatever
I'm writing people ask me you know what
comes first the music or the words it's
the idea that's the hard part is what do
you want to write about storytelling
yeah and that's what Broadway is about
and it's much easier and much more um
satisfying to write like that and as
opposed to writing a pop song which I
had to learn how to do once I found
myself in the pop music world cuz I
never really even listen to the pop
stations I i' never thought about my
being on the pop station singing pop
songs I never even listened to them and
so when I finally I mean I got a hit
record and I listened on the radio and I
heard kung fu fighting and Boogie Oogie
Oogie and I thought these people need me
but um you know um Mandy is a good
sounding record uh you know and I
understand why I mean I didn't
understand why it was a hit when it
became a hit but I do now the sound of
the record is um irresistible this guy
just came right through the speakers and
could you hear that when you first were
listening to it no not at all like do we
get to a point where we can fully
live
in the beautiful fortune and blessings
that we've come
into or will we also always have a
little bit of that Brooklyn kid who is
scared about what's going to happen in
life you know I never was scared really
no I was never scared that's strange
when I look back on it yeah even you I
was uh excited uh you know the first
time I actually had to walk onto a stage
and say good evening folks I mean I've
never were you scared about that well I
wouldn't say scared but I it was
exciting and it was I didn't really know
I stunk I didn't know what I was doing I
really I was terrible um the audience
didn't think so I was going to say I
don't feel like you ever stuck y I did
cuz I didn't know what I was doing but
when I sat at the
piano yeah I was okay when I sang at the
piano I never thought of myself as a
singer either but sure I'll I'll take
the gig and so I you know I played and
sang and everybody seemed to like that
but actually having a show where I'm I'm
the guy up front that was ridiculous i'
never thought about doing that it's way
it's
overwhelming it's overwhelming to stand
up there and get that kind of of of
approval
yes it's overwhelming so when you're
getting that kind of approval what do
you think in your head I stand there and
I say I wish theyd stop it I wish they'd
stop it I feel like you want to go it's
okay it's okay you don't have to do that
let me go to the next thing it's it's
hard to accept it you
know receive the love accept the love
you know I say to myself over and over
while they're trying to tell me thank
you it that part is the most difficult
for me it's easy to sing and run around
the stage it's hard to just stand there
and let them do their things that's the
hardest part for me I've never never
figured that one out I I get it I really
do